I mean I don't know how much I'm reading
cuz he asked me someone I don't get the
point can you read just just a few more
lines few more lines I read you two
lines already say two more L he's
changed Samuel now where is it going go
back to samel go back to Samuel man
there's only one more verse you can read
that last verse read it why you afraid
to read it what do you mean I already
read two no you didn't read the last two
okay you said you said three right where
is that is 15 the prophet marri Aisha
the prophet marri Aisha is this are you
claiming this is immoral uh is that my
water it's not my WaterOne get water
yeah please please go get water please
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a mid and Community Center in Norway and
they urgently need your support this
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you will in be
reaping a reward click the link and
donate what you can so next time you
learn a lesson today don't open your
mouth don't talk too much don't too much
you know what I'm breaking bad breaking
finished two SC done you're done you're
finished got cooked long time ago you
got roasted long time ago so you just
talking and talking didn't want me to
leave alhamdulillah come on
alhamdulillah come on me this what and
don't say why did Muhammad marry a
six-year-old Mar you want to go there oh
I don't you don't want to go there with
I'm going to have to take my shades off
again now I'm going to have to take my
shades off again now I'm not running
away okay let's go with it now I'm
running away what's your problem with
the pr marriage to Aisha one second
don't say Rebeca was three what no no no
no what's your problem one second what's
your argument look check this out cuz I
took my shades off now that has to be
consequen now you said are you say said
he he
said's father he said you are my brother
okay yeah but you are my okay now I'm
ask you a question are you claiming that
it is immoral in heaven come
on are you debating him or me are you
deting on me no I'm just saying I'm just
saying how is it okay if the own father
saying I accept the challenge now are
you saying
got you saying everyone's cooked but
you're the one who's burning not me you
got cooked by what's his name brother
brother brother brother everyone's
getting cooked by your own fire by my
own now now list listen the fire cons
you John says I baptized with water but
he who comes after me but he who comes
after me baptized with fire keep the
water to yourself now you said the
Propet marriage the Propet married Aisha
are you claiming now that's
right I'm saying I'm just saying we're
bringing a new subject up I'm just
saying yes you brought it up all right
remember I I didn't run away right I'm
standing right here yes you're getting
cooked now the pro marri Aisha the pro
Mar Aisha is this are you claiming this
is
immoral uh is that my water it's not my
water get yeah pleas please go get
please let me try to show off some money
and stuff like that buy water how I'm
going to show one water it's not champag
B water
okay now I'm asking a simple question is
the prophet marriage to Aisha immoral
according to you uh marrying 9year old
yes is it immoral she's not a woman
she's not a woman at 9 years old so is
it immoral she's not a woman at 9 years
old yes is it immoral she's a child
she's still playing with dolls she
playing with dolls imal it's a
child years old why is a girl is it
immoral yes okay good perfect what's the
standard listen carefully the prophet's
marriage to Aisha is according to him
immoral now you have to have consistency
who is more Superior a prophet or
God of course God perfect go to the Book
of Numbers Chapter you go to it this
time no problem now don't forget guys
what he said
marry don't forget now we're going to go
no first numbers no don't go
anywhere yes yes yes exactly yes now
let's go to Book of Numbers Chapter
18:31 why don't you listen
mesah you know you how you realize
anytime he's in trouble he backs up he
like a backup back Mah back back up yeah
my brother's keep it says iron sharpens
iron so one man sharpens the
other he knows what's coming he's
screaming now he's
like now he said that the prophet's
marriage what did we say guys let's go
with argument sake that he's calling the
prophet imal now he said God is far more
Superior than a prophet meaning a god
should know better his argument no
problem in the Book of Numbers Chapter
31:18 it says when you go to a land and
you kill all the fighting men any woman
any woman any no no no listen listen
listen listen but all the children any
girl that has not been touched by man
means she's a virgin keep them for
yourself now the question I want to ask
is is he keeping to himself to play
Monopoly are they playing Monopoly
because now is this moral or immoral
keeping little
girl imal so adop so so is adoption
wrong adoption is adoption wrong
adoption
ad it's showing that they're children
and they're not yet women that's what
it's saying keep them for your
understand understand the scripture is
ital oral children they're not yet
women it says the women who are not
virgin look let's not shout the woman
that's not virgin he says the woman
that's not virgin you kill them any girl
that has not been touched by man meaning
she's virgin Little Ghost keep them for
yourself what but why are you still
going by the Old Testament laws because
that's stup about Jesus no Jesus oh my
good Jesus fulfilled the law did he not
Jesus said I did not come to the law he
said marriage I did not come to now is
that don't run away don't run away but
fulfill it that's what he said and do
not change a single jot now is that
moral or imal
what is the law wait wait Jesus Tau you
about Mary your Messiah he your Messiah
moral keep little girls for
moral
you Jesus came
he oh my gosh one
[Applause]
second you want to see it that's the
teaching of your Messi he still he still
he's still in the Old Testament laws
mind you that's more than a thousand
years separation you feel me and Jesus
ain't had no slaves they just called
their own God
immoral talking about you just put words
in my mouth you just called immoral just
put words in my mouth again you just
called God immoral gave you words of
you're not Christian anymore gave you
scure you
justu teach
people I said keep little girls so so so
so because because because they did that
that's why Muhammad did that so now and
one so now that's why Muhammad did that
so now God is immoral thank you wa so
that's why Muhammad did that he married
a little girl because finish back in
numbers they took little girls virgin
finished you called God you called God
you're not Christian anymore wow how can
you call God y know that right anyway
guys who I hope this teaches you a
lesson the biggest terrorist are you
guys and guess what those words what
Israel is doing today you know what
script they quoting amikit IM they're
quoting amikit what was the conversation
about thank you very much it was a
pleasure you causing Terror when you
marry an iaus the terror when I open my
mouth finished
byee the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tala tells us that our books will be
given and every little at and weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a Masid oh
Allah you helped you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of as if you
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]